children may seem well equipped to deal
with covet 19
but the pandemic is leaving its mark
[Music]
school closures and isolation from
friends are bad enough
but some kids are forced to face the
pandemic alone
research shows over a million children
have lost at least one caregiver during
the crisis
robbing them of critical support and
exposing them to poverty
and abuse hi
i'm ben fazoulen nice to have you along
the pandemic has put some kids in an
extremely risky situation as you'll see
in our report in a moment
india is emerging from a deadly wave of
infections
it's claimed tens of thousands of lives
and
created a broken generation children and
teens
orphaned and exposed to not only
emotional trauma
but exploitation
for nine years now priti poddar has
worked with children from
underprivileged communities
on a daily basis she deals with children
who have experienced great loss
and are forced to grow up before they
are ready
but since the outbreak of covert 19
their numbers are growing
children are being made to quit
education and take up household
responsibilities
and are also being pushed into child
labour as their families have lost
income
secondly since they are spending a lot
of time at their home now
many cases of child abuse are also
coming up
having already been disproportionately
affected by covert 19
many children are facing another tragic
fallout of the pandemic
many have lost mothers or fathers or
both
leaving them extremely vulnerable since
last year the ngo where pretty works has
provided support to 13 children
who have been orphaned due to covert 19
by helping them settle in with their
extended families
sonal kapoor singh the founder of the
organization
says that while children who have been
orphaned have it much tougher
and need immediate attention a more
holistic approach is needed
to address every child in distress
there's a lot of conversation about
covered orphans
but honestly on the ground such cases
are probably five to six percent the
other 95
cases that we are looking at is where
the pair the very parents of these
children are pushing them into sexual
trade
transactional sex and child labor the
real issue really is to look at the
vulnerability mapping
of which child is in you know massive
distress and which child needs more
support
that there is a need for a more
comprehensive approach is something that
anurag kundu
the head of the delhi commission for
protection of child rights
also advocates for i think first three
things need to happen one
the schemes that provide financial
assistance to these families so that at
least a basic subsistence
is ensured the second thing that needs
to happen is
the governments have to explore ways of
keeping the children in school
the third either ensuring a livelihood
for the family
or ensuring that they are registered in
different existing schemes of the
government could be a russian
or whatever but ensuring that the family
has
adequate means as an immediate urgent
step
the commission has started a helpline
for children in distress
back at the center priti says that many
children she meets with
are in crisis right now
because of kovid years of hard work that
we and the children had put in
seem to have gone waste we are now
trying to get them back to their studies
and through different activities we are
trying to heal them
and help them come out of the difficult
situations they are facing
that despite their best efforts it will
be a long while before the children are
able to cope with the hurt
and the trauma that the pandemic has
inflicted
the ranger is a clinical psychologist
and works closely with national and
international
agencies she joins us from london in
india they're talking about a broken
generation are we seeing this elsewhere
um absolutely it is occurring elsewhere
but your question is always seeing it
and i think people are not focusing on
it
much to their detriment so for every
adult um
who succumbs to covert you would have
orphanhood for their children
and even for grandparents where it
clusters in all the generations
you have co-residing and caring grand
parents so children are dramatically
affected and we need to sharpen our lens
to them
just what sort of magnitude are we
talking about in in
some parts of the world uh well it's
high we have a paper coming out in the
lancet in a couple of weeks
that tries to create a model to quantify
it
um but it's related to the fertility
rates the size
of families and the burden of covert and
with that kind of reporting we are
seeing
uh figures um globally probably in
excess
of a million children and and growing
and growing we know in countries where
there's high fertility rates
more children are affected um and very
often that gravitates to low-income
countries
so looking at countries like india as
you say and south africa
but it's true across the usa across the
uk
um in brazil many many countries across
the continents
it's a global phenomenon wow another
concern is the pandemic seen
orphanages close and children sent back
to their communities
what happens then
um well that's a complicated story
because we know that
orphanages are probably not good places
for children to thrive we know this
before the pandemic and sadly amongst
the hiv epidemic
we saw them mushroom where we do have
very good evidence
that family care um is best for children
so um we we are looking at programs to
close orphanages and to
prop up families for example in uganda
there's an excellent program and in
rwanda
um but the planned closure is very
interesting issue so we could jump now
and and support the families we we can't
let
children go unsupported with no
resources
and maybe some of the
policies on child care and child care
in the sudden and abrupt absence of
adult care
needs to be brought into focus uh with
resources
we we shouldn't forget that this is a
covert casualty as well
lorraine have we learned anything from
other pandemics
absolutely so in ebola and in in hiv and
aids
we saw this mushrooming of children and
this huge vulnerability
we also know that the vulnerability
extends life long so once you've lost a
parent
or a child experience orphan hood we
know that it matters
who dies if it's a grandparent if it's a
mother if it's a father
and we know that a multiple burden like
double orphaning
or multiple loss it bodes really poorly
for the child
and we also know the age matters so the
younger the child the more dramatic the
long-term effects
and care responses are crucial so the
immediate care
and the ongoing sustained care and all
the kinds of disruptions
um like schooling and well-being
need to be plugged if the child is to
regain
we also know that if you do put in
interventions
they work so we have to be very cautious
of
poor quality care of excesses of
violence and abuse of such
children and having national and
government supported
good programming with a sharp lens on
children
hey lorraine share their clinical
psychologist she joins us from london
thank you very much for being on the
show today pleasure
pleasure time now for our science
correspondent derek williams out of your
question about how the virus affects
young adults
how does covet 19 tend to affect young
adults
there are two facets of this this
multi-faceted question that i'd like to
talk about
um the first is of course the
straightforward issue
of what the virus does physically to an
average young adult
as compared to someone who's older and
and there
the statistics tell a pretty clear story
covid19 mortality increases
dramatically with age let's look at
recent data from the u.s
more than four in five deaths there have
occurred
in those over 65 and
and fewer than one in 200 reported
deaths
have been in people under 30. but
as vaccinations rise among the elderly
in countries like the u.s
doctors say that the average age of
patients who are being hospitalized with
the disease
is dropping dramatically and that many
of those younger patients
will end up with conditions like
crippling damage to the lungs
or the heart so although covid19
is a lot less likely to kill a young
adult
there are still really pressing reasons
to get vaccinated because
getting it can have devastating
long-term health consequences
the second important facet of this
question is
is the pandemic's emotional social
uh psychological and economic impact
it's affecting everyone of every age but
his
experts say in many ways
hitting young adults especially hard and
and at a key time in their lives um
they're now warning that due
to lockdowns and other measures uh
generation covid
is facing shortfalls in opportunities
for for crucial self-development um
many young people are rising to the
challenges but
but psychologists and other therapists
in many places
like like here in germany are also
currently being
overwhelmed by this tidal wave
of young adults in need of help and
and a lot of those professionals now say
that even
the serious toll taken by infection in
today's young adults
could in the long run be overshadowed by
the impact coveted 19
has on the group's mental health
[Music]
derek williams there keep sending in
your questions just use our youtube
channel
finally some good news for residents of
delhi and mumbai
the government is easing lockdown
restrictions there as new infections in
india fall to a two-month low
shopping centres are reopening though
with some restrictions in place
public transport is operating again at
reduced capacity
the restrictions came in april after
india was hit with its most severe
corona outbreak to date
making india one of the world's worst
hit countries with around
29 million registered cases despite
easing restrictions authorities are
warning residents against
letting their guard down infections may
be falling but covert related deaths
remain at high levels
thanks for watching stay safe and see
you again soon
you